uh when when you made it big though um I
have to ask you are you're hitting with
ghosts you're doing all these things
you've got sexiest man alive you got
that
the seconds last year right
yeah come on now that is my mom was like
they had to pick that picture
my mom was like I think every dude I
know that gets in this list why did they
pick Ed that picture like I was like oh
I'm here for my library card
um yeah so um I'm the sexiest 38 year
old that came out in like October and I
turned 39 in December so I I held the
crown for all of like 45 days I've given
it away it was nice while I had it but
uh I had to abdicate the throne it's
gone that's awesome though yeah it was
cool I would show everyone hey yeah oh I
mean my wife was very happy about it
yeah yeah look look you're welcome she's
like well well you're 39 now so it
doesn't even count so dream is dead
sorry yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
yeah
[Music]